War changes people.
And this is something that we've known
since recorded history.
Um,
it's been spoken about in literature
throughout the ages.
It's kind of a brotherhood of combat
veterans.
And for many,
many years it stayed in the Brotherhood
and a lot of people came back from World
War Two.
Our fathers,
our grandfathers didn't talk about what
happened.
Um,
because nobody would understand what the
thing is that you're transformed inside.
You feel different.
Um,
you've seen things,
you've seen death,
you've see,
you've experienced,
you've tasted fear,
you've done things that you don't want
to talk about or you feel shouldn't be
talked about.
Um,
because it'll be too scary for people to
understand.
Ptsd is one of the most common mental
health conditions in the United States.
I think it's,
that map might be the fourth most common
condition.
Um,
and that's because,
um,
trauma is so prevalent in our society.
About 25% of women experience
interpersonal sexual violence,
which is extraordinary.
There are accidents,
natural disasters,
uh,
more than half of persons,
um,
will be exposed to at least one
traumatic event in their lives.
The way that I like to describe a
traumatic event is an event that kind of
divides your life into a before and
after,
like a watershed moment that really kind
of changes the way you view the world.
Whether or not you get post traumatic
stress disorder,
um,
it's big Europe,
you're leading your life a certain way,
something very big happens and it
changes the way that you look at
yourself and you look at the world.
So those kind of events are certainly
transformative.
Um,
they certainly have long lasting marks
and one of those,
um,
effects of trauma exposure can be the
development of posttraumatic stress
disorder.
Imagine if you see danger everywhere and
that you're really worried for your
safety that is going to affect almost
every interaction that you have at work.
You're going to be more on edge,
more irritable.
It can get you into fights with
coworkers or with your employer.
The idea that you can't really
experience pleasure or that you have a
restricted range of emotions is going to
affect you mostly in,
um,
social and interpersonal domains.
A lot of marriages have been by PTSD.
Um,
the spouse often really wants to help
the affected person,
but they're used to a certain closeness
or intimacy that they find is now more
difficult to access.
The hallmark of ptsd is that the memory
of the event becomes haunting.
Um,
it kind of takes on a life of its own.
You start thinking about what happened
just out of the blue or in response to
triggers in the environment.
And what's so distressing about the
memory is not that you just have an
image or remember what happened.
You have the physiologic feeling of fear
or horror that you had when the event
was occurring in real time.
So it's not only a,
a visual or or verbal memory out there,
it is a physiologic memory and this can
happen while you're awake.
It can happen while you're asleep in the
form of your dreams.
People that have ptsd have trouble
experiencing pleasure and it's all about
trying to become small and not,
not allowing yourself to be affected by
the environment.
Um,
it also includes really changing the way
you view the world and yourself.
The world's a bad place.
Um,
you might feel guilty or worthless.
You might feel you're to blame for what
happened or others are to blame.
And finally there are symptoms that
reflect increased arousal.
So people that have ptsd are on edge,
um,
their body and brain chemistry is rigged
for danger and for experiencing threat
and being very,
very concerned about anything in the
environment that might threaten them.
So the symptoms in this category include
being highly reactive to startle
responses.
I'm scanning the environment for signs
of danger and not being able to
concentrate on being very irritable and
angry.
Well,
nobody's going to wave a magic wand and
say,
I'm going to cure you being being anthro
fairy dust on you.
I'm getting over.
Ptsd is going to require some hard work
on the part of trauma survivor.
And there's no getting around that.
Um,
it's,
it's work to look in the mirror and know
that there's some part of you that's
gone forever.
There's work trying to understand
exactly what has and hasn't changed and
what can happen next.
PTSD treatment can be very,
very successful.
And I've seen it do wonders for people.
I've seen people go from being extremely
symptomatic to having very low symptoms
for a very long period of time.
But it's not something someone does to
you.
It's not in a little pill box that you
just swallow with water.
It really involves confronting what has
happened and con and
we sometimes fill it so much easier to
just try to put it in the past,
try to avoid it,
try not to think about it,
try not to deal with it.
But if we open ourselves up to,
um,
perhaps even the benefits or the ways
that we can grow the opportunities
provided to us by having these unique
experiences,
um,
then you can get past that hurdle.